Okay. Welcome back. Let's go and implement this thing.
Since we're addressing a global variable,
we need to declare it.
All we do is we take the command that's being input in here and append it to our list.
To see whether everything has been recorded properly,
we print out saved commands at the end of the execution.
Let's see how this works.
Here again we do have our three commands as they're being processed.
This is the recorded commands, namely: open, save, and quit.
If you're running this outside of the web page--
that is, on a command line--
then you can actually uncomment this line and interact with the program itself.
[The Infinite Abyss]